for more on the Orlando flooding let's
bring in Orange County Sheriff Jerry
Demings he is based in Orlando he joins
us now on the telephone sheriff Demings
good morning what can you tell us about
flooding in Orlando good morning we are
having considerable flooding in many
areas throughout our county here the
count is about a thousand square miles
and mostly in specific neighborhoods and
we've had to evacuate some neighborhoods
30 or 40 residents we see mostly is wind
damage trees down power lines down we
have about 250,000 of our residents who
are without power and you tell us about
the curfew mayor we understand that you
ever curfew there that's been in effect
since 7 o'clock last night
the sheriff sheriff Jennings that you've
had a curfew that's been in effect since
7 o'clock last night when do you think
it'll be safe for your residents to go
back outside and what's the purpose of
the curfew at this point at this point
the keep residents safe we have a number
of businesses that have been damaged in
which they haven't been able to secure
businesses and so we really want to
prevent the possibility of moving
occurring in different areas and also we
have quite a few traffic signals down
throughout the entire county and we have
trees still down crossing roadways so
our roadways are impassable and we
really just want to keep our public safe
we have downed power lines and and the
likes going on and so on for our
emergency crews our utility companies
are able to restore power get lines back
up get the traffic signals operational
and businesses are able to board up
their businesses and even some
residences we have trees that have
crashed to the rooftops homes and so all
of that needs to be taken care of so
that people who want to prey on
individuals who've been the victim of
this storm or not the further victimized
okay and how long do you think that'll
take quickly it's really an unknown but
it's going to be several hours because
we're still in the early phases of doing
our damage assessments throughout the
county and again it's a fairly large
County about a thousand square miles so
it's gonna take some time for us to get
through that process alright Sheriff
Jerry Demings we thank you for taking
the time to talk to us